From Bryan Singer, the director with the mutant
power to make Brett Ratner disappear, comes
X-Men: Days of Future Past.
If First Class wasn't enough prequel for you
and Last Stand wasn't last enough for you,
experience the prequel-sequel that made the
worst X-Men movie
irrelevant
and the worst Wolverine movie into a bad dream.
It's OK, it's OK, it's all gone now.
Shhh.
Journey to a time when humanity and mutants
alike are trapped in a Tron Legacy prison
Where only the plot of Terminator 2 can save
them, as an indestructible badass gets sent
back in time
without his clothes
to protect a vulnerable young man with long
hair
who will one day become a leader
and stop a shape-shifter from destroying the
future.
"Who sent you?"
"You did."
"The person who sent me... was you."
"What?"
In a world full of other cool X-Men, meet
Wolverine for the 7th
f***ing time.
Hugh Jackman returns to the role he could
play in his sleep by now
... which he does.
Watch as he's sent back to alter history the
only way he knows how:
spoiler alerts.
"You and I are gonna be good friends."
"I spent a lot of years trying to bring you
down."
"I was your most helpless student."
"In the future, do I make it?"
"No."
Spend the other half of your time with characters
like
Charles Xavier, the young mutant heroin addict,
Hank McCoy, his enabler,
"I added a little extra cuz you missed a dose."
Quicksilver, a mutant so powerful he could
single-handedly solve
every problem the X-Men will ever have
which is probably why they leave him at home,
and Mystique, a mutant so stubborn she'd rather
cause the apocalypse than listen to reason.
"Humans use your blood, your genes, to create
a weapon that wipes us all out."
"Please do not make us the enemy today."
"Get out of my head, Charles!"
"If you kill Trask, you'll be creating countless
more just like him."
"Then I'll kill them too."
When your psychic friend, his mortal enemy,
and a dude from the
future are all telling you the same thing,
you should probably listen to them, idiot.
So get ready for a super-powered snuff film
where everybody dies
but, also, nobody dies.
And witness an epilogue that ties up all loose
ends, where all your favorite X-Men show up
alive and well,
which totally undermines the stakes of X-Men:
Apocalypse,
but who cares? This scene was awesome!
Top that, Avengers!
Starring
PowerPoint
Magnets, How Do They Work?
The Flash
Reverse Austin Powers
Storm Thurmond
Mysteets
Kelsey Syntax
Oldneto
Megamind
The Other Gay Ellen
I'm Tiny Ron Burgundy?
And Ultron
X-Men: Timecop.
So, if this movie takes place in 1973, and
Wolverine: Origins takes place in 1986, Charles
is gonna go from this to this
in 13 years?
Yikes.